brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or bricks
or whatever to help the people in Gaza
but then just imagine this amazing de
that you want to do but we turn it into
a money-making machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys brother sisters hope you guys are
well in we are standing in front of a
church which has been here for many many
years really yes it has a amazing
history behind it no way yes it is which
we're going to find out which was told
actually U we're here in Bosnia with
Sabor and Zan brother Edie from invited
please yes he invited us may Allah bless
show us this we we have this historical
event right we have the war that took
place and we had mid being destroyed
more than 600 but what were the Muslims
doing were they reciprocating and doing
the same to the Christians this was
amazing man because you know the Hate
Machine the islamophobia machine you you
guys know you see them always attacking
and throwing these absurdities out there
that Islam you know uh radical Muslims
you know want to kill all the infidels
and whatnot but you have a living
example here in the Jerusalem of Europe
where you had
617 617 churches MOS that were destroyed
to the ground but this is an example of
just one the the churches were not
touched and this is one of the key
examples of those churches that were not
touched they were actually uh purposely
because the serbs were the actually
Christian chetes they were attacking uh
the Muslims they wanted to purposely
preserve this one and you have it here
right here in front of you interesting
so basically the the story behind is
that basically as you know when the
serves were in the genocide and killing
the Muslims here the bosnians Subhan
Allah as you know that with every
faction there's a group of individuals
who gets hatred their hatred of blinds
their FA faith in the sense where in our
religion it does not teach us that they
are our teachers what uh Bush may Allah
deal with them did in Iraq and
Afghanistan they are not our teachers
our teachers the prophet wasallam so
that's why because the Bosnian Army came
here and protected the church just in
case factions of Muslim groups who have
some kind of animosity Vengeance and
they were there to shows us what that
our religion doesn't teach us because
otherwise it would be the other way
around they would have attack the church
but rather the majority came together
against the minority of Muslims and
protected this church and also a message
they sent to the serbs that you are not
our teachers you destroyed over what 6
600 600 plus mosques I mean that's not
coincidence 64 614 look in war you can
say you know you hit a mosque by
accident it was 2 3 600 is Not an
Accident it shows targeted exactly but
the Muslims did not do the samean any
last words and you know what in London
we saw with the Southport stabbings
exactly that initially the church uh the
mosques were being tar targeted however
when the Muslims came out on the roads
they outnumbered the far right but not
one single church was attacked in fact
one viral video was of a mased man
standing in front of a church and saying
they're attacking our mosques here's
what we're going to do and he took his
mask off and said this is not what we're
taught to do one famous Christian you
can see him you know chewing the Quran
spitting it out but I made a video
alhamdulillah quite a while back in
which I said you know what it's time for
Revenge held up the Bible and I said you
know what even now I keep it on my top
shelf I don't disrespect it because this
is what we're taught to do and this is a
fantastic example of that that's crazy
the irony Subhan Allah what happened in
in the UK with the ri started it was not
the Muslim it was not a Muslim who done
it was a Christ it was a
Christian exactly boyo boy and his
family's St church goers yeah and he was
not even a Muslim and they still
targeted a mosque and here you had
people targeting mosque and Muslims
saying we're not targeting churches you
can't make this stuff come to Bosnia uh
and discover the history the landscape
the nature insh which we're going to go
to tomorrow and accept Islam inshallah
how do they do that by saying Ashu no
they watch inshallah videos and
especially Eddie from the dean show
inshah why because this is the dean n a
bit mad they say the
Shah the
sh so many people you know the wonderful
thing about the internet is it's
happened here with Eddie but it's also
happened in other random spots people
watch the dean show and they watch these
types of things in the most remote parts
of the world yes so The Message of Islam
is getting through to people that you
cannot even expect so whoever you are at
home if you don't know what you can do
for the da at least you can share a
video and if you have the right
intention you never know you can lead
someone to Islam so look to end the
video we're going to speak about Kenia
living together the Jerusalem of Europe
proves what Muslims no matter how
brutalized they were in the war they
didn't break their principles they
didn't attack the churches churches they
protected the communities around them
the Jewish communities the Christian
communities and remember the Orthodox
and the Catholics hated each other here
but Muslims did not get involved in that
war they rather protected because that's
what Islam teaches us to do not to do
those things and obviously like you said
they're not our teachers
Med